even the holidays that he's mentioning
is even still a problem what about
because when I ask him for holidays it's
not like he even still wants to provide
as Wellen this woman wants me to give
her £15,000 for her to go on a 4- day
trip to Miami oh okay the cost of living
is just stupid these days and she wants
me to give her 15 grand so go go go
waste on you already know how I live my
life mind I haven't lost my
mind 15 grand okay guys let's just be
objective we have a chick that's maybe
slightly above average she's what a six
six five six I mean who knows under all
that makeup we don't even know what she
looks like and she's demanding I mean
honestly I would say that's like nine
prices